let's ask one of our front-end engineers
how he does the same thing
now he's hard at work so I'm gonna have
to find some way to get his attention
and remind him that he agreed to talk
with us
I think the dart gun should do the trick
hi I'm Jacques I'm the lead front-end
engineer at Udacity and I've been with
the company now for about two and a half
years and I was just gonna run you
through sort of how I approach a new
design so when I get something like this
everything on the web is boxes so I
start out sort of understanding and
cutting up the boxes that I'm going to
use and that starts with the big box
that is your whole page and from there I
sort of split it up piece by piece and
we work from big to small so in the
first cut it's gonna be there's a big
box at the top here for your head
content your logo your text that kind of
stuff you have a big box here with your
image in it and you have a big box here
with this footer all these footer
elements and as you can see actually
inside of the footer there are three
sort of small boxes with those image and
text and one sort of box that goes
across the top of it with this featured
work and so I work from the from the big
side into the small side and when I
started out I did this with the pencil
you know you start drying out here's a
big box this is gonna be the header and
you can actually fill in the content
later you don't actually have to worry
about it you can move from the big to
the small so how you're gonna position
this logo here how you're gonna make
this text show up you can put that off
until later those are smaller boxes so
start with the big boxes and work down
from there so just sketch it out and as
you do this more often you'll be able to
do it start doing it in your head but if
you get if you're having any trouble
especially starting out just go for a
pencil it's a it's a great tool